it's been a long time since anyone
tented thus images garden and even now
it's quite an effort for Sasha's image
he did not return home voluntarily his
father built the house but it's almost
all facade he didn't have the money to
finish it Sasha's image and his family
inhabit the only two livable rooms and
constantly wish they were in Germany but
that chapter is over police hammered on
the door and my wife opened it we showed
them to doctors certificates stating
that I have a chronic heart condition
that I may not travel in this condition
and that my life is endangered in Serbia
because I cannot get the necessary
treatment here but they said pack your
essentials so I was only able to take my
documents and one small bag with me a
passport stamp sealed their deportation
German authorities refused to accept
discrimination against Roma in Serbia as
a reason for granting asylum after six
months in Germany in mid-october thus
images had to leave the bitter taste of
failure is what remains many Serbians
can't find work and the Roma have no
chance at all nine out of ten asylum
seekers from Serbia are Roma their
representatives say it's not just
because they're poor the poverty has
been a problem for many generations on
top of that they face discrimination
from the moment they're born until they
die in all areas of life for example in
education in the job market and in the
healthcare system the German government
says that's not its problem it
classifies Serbia as a safe country of
origin and Roma as economic migrants
this angers many liberal Serbs
obviously the top burger it's an attempt
to shift the blame onto an ethnic
minority like all countries in the
region Serbia is trying to present its
best face in Brussels and to signal that
it's not a source of asylum seekers even
though it is one due to its economic
situation dr. Costa see [ __ ] yeah but
the symmetries desperation is growing
from one day to the next if they could
they would try their luck in Germany
again